cubits to be more concrete let's consider a simple noise model where errors occur independently on the cubits
with each Cubit experiencing an error with probability p and with no correlation between errors on different
cubits the worst case scenario for the 9 Cubit sh code is that a y error or in other words both an X error and a z
error occurs on each of fected Cubit and we'll assume this worst case scenario just for the sake of obtaining a bound
on the code's performance but you could also consider for instance that the three poly errors are equally
likely now suppose that Q is a cubit in some particular state that we'd like to protect against errors and imagine that
we have the option to use the 9 Cubit Shore code should we use it well the answer is not necessarily
yes because if there's two much noise or in other words p is too large using the shore code could actually make things
worse just like we had for the repetition code when p is larger than 1/2 but if p is small enough then the
answer is yes we should use the code so let's see why this is and what it means for p to be too large or small
enough for this code the shore code can correct any poly error on a single Cubit and in the worst
case where are poly errors are y errors this means that the code successfully protects Q with a probability given by
the expression shown on the screen specifically the code works when there are no errors and that happens
with probability 1 minus p ^ 9 because there are nine cubits that must each be unaffected and it works when there's
exactly one error and considering that there are nine different cubits that could possibly be affected this happens with probability 9 * P * 1 - p ^ 8
on the other hand if we didn't bother using the code our one and only Cubit would be unaffected by an error with
probability one minus P so the code only helps when the first probability is larger than the second
because these Expressions represent our probabilities of success in the two cases when we use the code and when we
don't here's a plot of these two functions for small values of p and we find that the break even Point occurs at
about 3 and a/4 per. so if p is smaller than this value then the code
helps at the break even point the probabilities are equal so we're just wasting our time along with 8 cubits if
we use the code but otherwise there's no harm in it and beyond that point we should absolutely not be using this code
because it's actually increasing the chance of an error on the encoded Cubit which we typically refer to as the
logical cubit in this context and that's happening simply because the chance of two or more errors on nine cubits is
larger than the chance of one error on a single Cubit for values of p in this range 3 and a/ qu% may not seem very
good particularly when compared to 50% which is the analogous Break Even point for the three-bit repetition code for
classical information but it's harder to protect Quantum information and moreover although this
code represents a brilliant Discovery as the very first Quantum error correcting code and it happens to be great for pedagogical purposes the fact of the
matter is that it's just not all that good of a code in Practical terms so far we've considered X errors
and Z errors in the context of the 9 Cubit Shore code now let's consider arbitrary errors
starting first with unitary errors so for example such an error could correspond to a very small
rotation of the block sphere possibly representing an error that's incurred by a gate that isn't perfect for instance
or it could be any other unitary operation on a cubit and not necessarily something close to the identity
operation it might seem like correcting for such errors is difficult there are infinitely many possible errors like
this and it's inconceivable that we could somehow identify exactly what error it is and then undo it but we
don't actually need to do anything different from what we've already discussed as long as we can correct for a bit flip a phase Flip or both then we
will in fact suc succeed in correcting for an arbitrary single Cubit unitary error and I'll now explain why that
is first like all 2x two matrices we can express an arbitrary unitary Matrix
representing an error on a single Cubit as a linear combination of the four poly matrices including the identity
Matrix and by the way as you may have noticed I'm using capital X Y and Z to denote the non-identity polym matrices
and I'll continue to do that for the remainder of this series that's conventional in Quantum error correction and it also makes
things a bit easier to read in this context it's also going to be convenient to use subscripts to indicate which
Cubit a given Cubit unitary operation acts on so for example if we use Kit's
Cubit numbering convention starting from Cubit zero on the right then we have the Expressions shown on the screen for
various unitary operations on single cubits where in each case we tensor the unitary Matrix with the identity Matrix
on every other Cubit so in particular we can express UK meaning U applied to Cubit K as the same
linear combination as before except that each poly Matrix is applied to Cubit K we don't need to bother with the
subscript for the identity by the way the understanding here is that this is the identity on all the
cubits now suppose that SII is the 9 Cubit encoding of a cubit state if the the error U happens to
Cubit k then we obtain u k * s which we can express as a linear combination of poly operations acting on S which of
course is just s in the case of the identity at this point it's going to be helpful to observe that the poly y
Matrix is equal to I * x * Z so we can make that substitution in our
expression so this error has taken place and now suppose that we attempt to correct it using the same procedure as
four the first step is to compute the syndrome which in the case of the sh code is 8 Bits long two bits for each of
the three times we use the inner code along with an additional two bits for the outer code but it doesn't really matter we can just think about it as
some fixed length string here's a description of the state that we get just prior to the measurement of the syndrome where each
syndrome is whatever eight bits we get from the corresponding poly error notice at this point that the two
systems are Cor ated in general and really this is the key to making all of this work by measuring the syndrome what
we'll effectively do is to collapse the state into one where one of the four poly operations has been applied to the
Ki cubi of sigh and we'll know from the syndrome which poly operation it was so we can correct it if
needed in particular if we measure the syndrome and make the appropriate correction then we obtain a state of the